[Musique]
bonjour heureux de vous retrouver pour
ce nouveau numéro de 7,8 échos dédié au
ski cube située à guyancourt
alors le ski cube c'est un incubateur
qui a pour but d'aider les startups à se
développer plus rapidement
alors quelles sont les forces du ski
tube sommaire
nous allons rencontrer philippe moreau
directeur d'un cube alliance
l'incubateur technologique du campus de
paris saclay nous verrons avec lui
pourquoi il a participé au projet du ski
cube
nous irons voir aussi en en cubes et
magdalena mauconduit elle a créé un
service de livraison communautaire et à
la choisit l'incubateur saint quentinois
pour donner un coup de pouce à son
business
et puis nous interview jean michel
fourgous vice président en charge du
développement économique à saint quentin
en yvelines
il est à l'initiative de ce projet mais
tout d'abord faisons un point sur la
situation économique à saint quentin en
yvelines saint quentin en yvelines c'est
seize mille établissements français
internationaux près de 145 mille emplois
dans des secteurs d'activité diversifiés
c'est le deuxième pôle économique dans
l'ouest parisien après la défense c'est
aussi le premier pôle commercial des
yvelines 12 communes six pôles
économiques et 4,6 millions de m²
d'immobilier d'entreprise c'est grâce à
toutes ses forces que saint quentin en
yvelines a peut attirer des
collaborateurs pour la conception du ski
cube comme philippe moreau directeur
d'un cube alliance nous allons nous
entretenir avec lui
un jour je me more on alors dites moi
vous avez contribué à ce ch'ti cube
pourquoi effectivement aujourd'hui est
un grand jour puisque on ouvre ce ski
cube
cela fait partie d'un projet qu'on avait
commencé à aborder et à discuter avec
les services de la de la communauté à
l'époque et petit à petit l'idée d'une
collaboration étroite entre
incuballiance et le ski cub a fait jour
et elle se concrétise aujourd'hui avec
l'ouverture de ce lieu merveilleux
vous avez contribué à l'incubateur à
paris saclay là c'est celui de saint
quentin en yvelines
juste une question comme ça il n'y a pas
trop d'incubateur c'est une bonne
question et on pourrait discuter de ce
point effectivement il y as depuis
maintenant une petite dizaine d'années
l'explosion du nombre d'incubateur on
peut le voir positivement et un peu plus
négativement positivement parce que cela
veut dire que l'initiative
l'entrepreneuriat l'innovation tout cela
à prix 1
un réel et vol en vol dans notre pays
c'est évident dans les écoles dans les
universités chez les salariés et c'est
un peu plus négativement puisque c'est
une industrie qui effectivement devient
très concurrentiel et qu'on doit attirer
les meilleurs projets c'est le rôle d'un
incubateur de pouvoir sélectionner les
projets très en amont et sélectionner
les meilleurs mais comme toute industrie
cette industrie va petit à petit se
structurer il y aura des gagnants il y
aura des perdants c'est la vie et c'est
plutôt bien
hélas ce qui vous a intéressé vous me
l'avez dit en off parce qu'on a un petit
peu préparé cette interview c'est que
les élus ont vraiment travaillé sur ce
projet sont motivés ça exactement et je
trouve que l'état doit effectivement que
des ieg des élus dès le départ ont porté
ce projet ça c'est évident et ils ont
abordé de manière un petit peu j'allais
dire
même carrément intelligente c'est à dire
qu'ils se sont dits plutôt que de créer
quelque chose à partir de zéro utilisons
déjà le savoir faire existant sur la
région sud francilienne et incuballiance
par définition et l'incubateur de
référence un petit peu du sud francilien
en matière d'entreprises innovantes et
technologique puisque nous sommes nous
existons depuis 15 ans et qu'il n'y a
plus de 300 projets qui ont déjà été
imprimés chez incuballiance eu depuis
depuis les débuts et c'est quoi le but
c'est de faire comment un territoire
dédié au monde de l'entreprise parce
qu'il ya déjà paris-saclay via le ski
cube gestes qui vont travailler ensemble
alors l'agglomération de 50 ans fait
partie de ce grand projet kloster paris
saclay donc tout le sud ouest sud
francilien est appelé à devenir une des
zones les plus comment dirais-je les
plus les plus riches en matière de
création d'entreprises d'innovation
technologique de science est tout
simplement d'économies dans les 10
années qui viennent voilà ça attire les
investisseurs ce genre d'émulation se
terrer ce type de territoire qui bouge
oui nous on voit à l'incubateur notre
place on voit de plus en plus de
d'universités étrangères de fonds
d'investissements alors dans notre
jargon c'est le capitaliste des gens qui
sont prêts à investir dans des projets
très en amont on les voit venir vers
nous se renseigner sur cet écosystème
sur l'agglomération de saint quentin sur
les entreprises qui émergent et
technologies qui sont un petit peu
rennes par rapport à d'autres et c'est
d'accord ok et par rapport aux 1 cube et
c'est un coup de boost pour leur société
écoutez moi je pense que en 2016 bientôt
2010 est monté sur l'entreprise surtout
si elle est effectivement innovante est
adossé à de la technologie souvent
numérique le faire dans son garage
quand vous pouvez le faire il ya 20 36
culte possible c'est totalement jaillir
c'est totalement idiot il faut qu'un
entrepreneur puisse se saisir des outils
qu'on lui propose que les que la
communauté des citoyens qu'ils proposent
et qu'ils en fassent j'allais dire le
meilleur usage
et puis façon propre cocktail c'est un
entrepreneur c'est lui qui doit trouver
la bonne adéquation et l'incubateur ski
kull sera là et au tout début son projet
lorsque notre président a encore créé ou
qu'elle vient juste d'être créée que les
clients ne sont pas encore là que le
produit se cherche encore on appelle ça
une phase d'amorçage early stage en
anglais le ski cube sera à ses côtés
sera probablement son son son partenaire
j'allais dire principal
il n'exclut pas les deux bien sûr qu'ils
sont mobilisés à travers le réseau du
scud dont on parle et les miens je
remercie monsieur moreau et tout de
suite on va passer à un autre sujet on
vient de parler d en cubes et et bien
focus sur l'entreprise taken by vous
allez voir c'est vraiment intéressant
bonjour moi c'est beau non je suis super
livres imprimés sûreté que vous je
voyage où tu donnes décidé de m'inscrire
sur tech nba pourrait faire j'ai alors
décidé de proposer de la place dans les
vagues
nos avantages je ris le coût des trajets
et je participe à l'écologisation a
besoin du diplôme soyez simplement un
collégien et cette idée de livraison
communautaire et nous vient de magdalena
mauconduit fondatrice de l'entreprise
taken by et qui est l'une des premières
incubés du ski tube alors le côté
innovant c'est qu'on donne le pouvoir
aux utilisateurs puisque c'est eux qui
vont fixer le prix du service très
important c'est également le nom
utilisateur qui va trouver son livreur
en fonction de différents paramètres à
savoir les notes attribuées par les
utilisateurs
le statut du livreur ou encore
l'identification du livreur autre chose
c'est que c'est interactif
en fait vous avez la possibilité
d'interagir en fait avec le livreur
et bien une communication via
l'application c'est une communication
gratuite et vous pouvez suivre en temps
réel le la livraison comme s'il y avait
un gps en fait sur sur l'application une
idée ambitieuse site efficace où il est
très simple de s'inscrire
la fondatrice souhaite mettre toutes les
chances de son côté et c'est pour cette
raison qu'elle a souhaité intégrer le
ski cube un très important je souhaitais
rentrer dans un
l'incubateur parce que ça formidable
accélérateur pour les entrepreneurs
on est entouré de personnes extrêmement
qualifiés notamment dans les questions
juridiques faut savoir pour que ce type
de projet dans l'économie collaborative
on a 10 milliards de questions des
questions juridiques sur n'importe quoi
le transport le domaine de l'économie
collaborative donc voilà être entourés
d'experts ça permet d'avancer un petit
peu plus vite
pour le moment la prochaine mission de
magdalena mauconduit c'est la recherche
de commerçants dans l'hexagone pour
affiner son projet et vous avez pu le
voir lors de ce reportage le ski tube va
devenir très important pour les startups
en devenir dans l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines
mais il est temps maintenant de faire un
point avec jean michel fourgous
vice-président à saint quentin en
yvelines est en charge du développement
économique
bonjour mais bonjour ou alors ce ch'ti
tube c'est un petit peu votre bébé
les goûters la création d'entreprise ce
doit être le bébé de la france où
d'entière bien sûr à saint quentin
oui de deuxième pib par habitant en
france après paris on se doit bien
entendu de d'accélérer aussi de profiter
de cette qualité des réseaux
d'entreprise et de l'offrir
bien sûr aux jeunes créateurs
d'entreprise assez de saint quentin
donc voilà le ski cube c'est avant tout
un accélérateur de croissance
un accélérateur de contact des changes
en même temps très rapidement ps2 de
concentration de savoir faire qu'on leur
donne encore avec dans laissez moi c'est
quasiment les clients d'une grande école
de commerce et donc c'est un réseau
c'est des contacts qu'ils ont un
animateur ils ont incuballiance qui est
quand même le numéro un de la dette de
l'animation de l'incubateur ils ont des
locaux quand même très sympathique qui
sont à dix minutes du d'une gare sont à
30 minutes en voiture quasiment sans feu
rouge ou de paris bon ben voilà cent en
dehors des déblocages les matins et
soirs mais dont vous là ils ont tout
pour eux ils ont en même temps on les
aide à monter leur prototype a à
répondre c'est de savoir créer une
entreprise quel statut juridique
où trouver les moyens financiers des
partenaires les partenaires les premiers
talents qu'ils vont engager dans les
employés comment remplir un crédit impôt
recherche comment créer un
circuits de distribution de production
bien sûr avant de d'exportation donc
voilà en fait ils ont deux ans pour bien
sûr accélérer leurs projets c'est
important pour saint quentin en yvelines
d'avoir son incubateur à écouter on peut
pas vouloir jouer dans la cour des
grands en valais de demain avec cette
clé est bon il faut bien entendu et
surtout la qualité des grandes
entreprises que nous avons aidé moyenne
est toujours très innovante
bien sûr qu'aujourd'hui on a les moyens
de se lancer à l'assaut de ce projet
d'accélération de la création
d'entreprise à saint quentin mais seul
être un modèle français on est on est
ici je vous dis on est le deuxième pays
mais comme je disais sur en france après
paris donc on doit être un modèle pour
qu'eux aussi d'autres
d'autres villes sont inspirés que et que
le pays tout entier soient mobilisés
pour créer des entreprises beaucoup plus
d'avenir sur des sauts des marchés où il
ya une forte croissance c'est le cas de
la sélection ici on prend on prend des
gens bien sûr qu'ils ont des projets sur
des marchés à forte croissance et bien
sur l'accompagnement de qualité motivant
et toujours aussi un avec amour il faut
il faut montrer je connaissais et et
vous les aimez il faut passer par un
acte froissé c'est franchement les
mettre dans une ambiance extrêmement
stimulant de jeu vous sont très
optimistes et vous m'avez même parlé
d'une future silicon valley donc on en
avait pas en france est la nôtre elle
existe écoutez a priori avec
avec l'exemple du mythique nous a placés
dans les huit zones mondial d'innovation
avec saclay bien sûr qu'on a tous les
moyens de réussir ce pari était un grand
pari d'être la silicon valley à la
française qui sort effectivement les
meilleurs break it is or les meilleurs
talents les meilleures formations voilà
c'est une seule il faut il faut viser
l'excellence pour pour remettre notre
pays d'ailleurs sur sur un niveau de vie
qui leur est jamais dû perdre parce
qu'il est tellement de qualités dans ce
pays donc voilà on veut être un en
concentration en tout cas de ses
qualités d'excellence de ses talents et
de ses moyens convention offrir à tous
nos jeunes sélectionnés bien sûr de
saint quentin il faut être de 50 un lieu
sûr pour pouvoir peut souffler et pour
finir elle est une petite question comme
ça
cinquante ans on est déjà la terre
d'innovation on est en devenir
on est déjà une terre d'innovation c'est
quand même une réussite c'est quand même
une des villes nouvelles qui a le mieux
réussi
donc c'est quand même on part on part
pas de zéro il faut être direct ça va de
soi mais l'accélération la concurrence
entre les territoires augmentant ou
entre les pays
bien sûr qu'aujourd'hui les règles sont
un peu différents en plus avec le
tsunami du numérique il faut il faut
aller très vite aujourd'hui donc on se
sont débrouillés d'accélération bien sûr
de cette réussite dans des biens placés
dans la course
oui mais mais il faut pas se reposer sur
ses lauriers vous savez la vie est faite
comme ça aussi bien sur le plan
personnel que sur leurs professionnels
chaud le plan estudiantin il faut le
monde bouge très vite et il faut montrer
quand on est en mouvement et qu'on est
que voilà qu'on construit les courants
qui gagne et c'est le but de saint
quentin est un courant qui gagne on peut
guère fait d'accord vous voilà merci
messieurs fonderie merci aux basses
maintenant à l'agenda
une date à noter lancement de skate ou
une veste la plateforme de crowdfunding
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
l'agglomération vous propose un nouvel
outil de financement pour booster votre
développement il s'agit d'aider les pme
à faire face aux difficultés d'accès aux
financements afin qu'elles puissent
innover et embaucher dans les meilleures
conditions l'événement se déroule au
skate au ski cube à guyancourt le 14
décembre 2016
à 18h30 7,8 échos c'est fini bonne
journée à tous
[Musique]